The Joe Rogan experience.
So when you're,
you got into stand up comedy.
When you first started doing that,
what is the scene like in England is that was their comedy clubs where you could
go to an open mic night?
We were,
how do you,
we were copying you guys.
I think Lenny Bruce set up the more alternative version cause,
but I still think in America it's always stayed kind of mainstream.
But Lenny Bruce was definitely doing alternative and as you got lots of Lenny,
I love that guy.
Yeah.
You know,
I played them on stage and that was a wonderful thing.
What did you play them in?
What was that Lenny,
you know the film was from a stage play,
Dustin Hoffman film.
That was a stage play.
Dustin Hoffman was fantastic.
He was so close.
And the guy who plays him in the marvelous Mrs Maysville is very good as well.
I know that's very interesting to say because I'm watching that.
I'm thinking,
okay now I've,
I've gone through the clubs myself,
but I did mine in the 80s and into the 90s and that's in this fifties wow.
I sort of take myself there.
Then there's Lenny.
Then I think he,
I know Lenny and I play them.
I used to Dianne and I go,
that's me.
They'll get that.
But I was,
I was doing the standup.
I W I see that the photo I put,
I put that together.
That was,
and I called him to Jesus crisis of comedy because as a Jewish guy,
he died for us to die for us to give us the freedom of speech.
Yeah.
He died for freedom of speech because in the end,
a little of heroin too.
I know,
but the mixture together,
he shouldn't have conflated the two.
Yeah.
He meant that we could say what we want to do.
I'm saying the missus nasal things makes it a little,
it's a little homogenized like him,
like,
and even his struggle,
it's almost like it's no big deal.
Are you,
are you in the latest season?
Is it,
is it three or two to three hasn't released yet.
They're filming it right now.
I've gone through both of them.
It's really good.
Yeah.
Really,
it's just not accurate.
Like historically it's way off the mark.
There's no woman who was talking like that back then.
It wasn't,
there was no mrs main song.
Like I really liked it and uh,
it's interesting sheet.
Yeah,
like norm McDonald got mad about it until he was like,
man,
I,
there was no woman like that back then.
There was a she,
there's no,
it doesn't,
I can we keep it to,
if it's a fucking show,
man,
the hawks not really there.
There's no guy who becomes the hawk now.
I enjoy it.
I really liked normally talk about I love him.
Yeah.
I didn't have,
there was a,
she was swearing like a,
like a soldier on the stage very quickly,
very quickly.
Which that was,
I found,
I don't know how she ramped into that and then she dropped down out of it.
It was,
that was something was by,
and then she went to France and I wanted absurd and did stand up that someone
was translating and like that was weird.
I have done it in French and I don't think I could've got that,
that I didn't know why that,
that seemed just seemed to be slightly sharp jumping a shot,
going up to the shock and swimming around in ships,
artistic interpretation.
They,
they,
it wasn't realistic,
but it still,
it was a,
and as a person who makes a living doing standup comedy,
I was willing to let that suspension of disbelief taste.
I like the,
the sexual relationship is it always coming back?
The husband's omens coming back into the frame and his,
and his fight that,
um,
cause yeah,
but now I,
I did watch it.
I binge watched it.
Oh,
that's what I'm doing.
I just sit down and I just watched everything.
Yeah.
And then I moved on.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
Lenny,
um,
how do we get into Lenny,
which we're talking about something else.
But anyway,
now he's great.
He's great playing Lenny,
but Oh yes,
I was,
I was doing this style apps and I was just told by Director Peter Hall,
I'll leave the stand up to you.
So I had no direction on it.
So I just did it as close as I could to have Lenny would have done it.
Did you listen to a lot of recordings?
I did that.
That is very difficult for birdish uh,
cage maybe even met and kids of today to know cause he's doing a lot of hipster
references.
A lot of the other Sophie Tucker references and there's a,
there's a Lawrence Welk as it that Welsh,
Welsh,
yeah.
We don't know those guys.
So when he was doing,
that's cool.
Is this Sophie Tucker and the guy I could look up.
So today I'd have to look up the,
some of the punchlines or enough of that number of the references cause you
without the references you can't get it.
This is a trick I do in universal humor that I take either huge references or
explain my references so that you know,
uh,
sees it.
Everyone probably knows about season if they don't.
Well,
yeah.
Anyway,
good as Lenny was,
it's really hard for people to listen to that comedy today.
It doesn't necessarily trans,
it doesn't transfer.
Well,
he's talking about Nixon and you're like,
oh Nixon,
no,
this is,
this is a vice president Nixon and this is Eisenhower,
Nixon,
different thing.
Um,
so he,
I worked out that all the,
all my stuff is non datable is no,
I didn't do any topical stuff.
Identity politic,
political stuff.
So it should not date.
I do historical stuff cause that never dates,
you know,
sees it,
is not going to come back.
Now sees his,
changed his whole thing.
He's much nicer though.
He's come back from the dead and he's,
he's cleaned up his act.
Um,
so I've,
I've tried to do that.
And Python did this as well.
You do stuff.
It just doesn't really date.
Most of it doesn't date.
Um,
which is a handy thing.
So the stuff,
guns,
yeah,
second.
But I did much stand up does,
and it's also the,
the,
the culture.
So significantly different between the late fifties and sixties,
where Lenny Bruce was sort of starting out and making his mark versus today.
It's like the things that were naughty back then.
The things that he could say that were controversial.
There were nothing today.
They're the,
literally it's a non controversy,
whether there's one that it still was,
was when he said how many people using the n word,
the that's working,
they just went to all the,
how many are in the [inaudible]?
How many of you went and I did this,
I used to do that on stage every night.
And that was still a striking tense.
Yeah.
But the,
the sentiment behind it was that these words only have power because,
cause we're giving them permission and if you could use them again,
again,
and for the gay community,
they taken the word queer.
Reclaim that.
Yeah.
So it doesn't have the force anymore.
And that,
that is a truth.
He spoke,
he was at,
that was a true analysis that he did.
Yeah.
It was,
um,
we had some still Joe,
there was a UN,
unfortunately,
accidentally,
a friend of mine stole one of his jokes and didn't know that.
He actually just thought of the same premise.
Yeah.
And he was the,
the premise was that,
uh,
homosexuality in some places and illegal.
And what do they do if they catch you?
Well,
they lock you up in jail with a bunch of men who want to have sex with you.
Like in that was Lenny Bruce's line by like Digg,
homosexuality is illegal,
right?
And so what do they do?
They put you in jail with a bunch of men will have sex with you.
You know,
like,
that was his whole like,
and like,
that still would work today.
Like if there was a place or homosexuality was illegal today and you did that
joke,
it's a good joke.
It's like set up punch lines.
All right.
There.